[Music]
forests provide a home
to most of the biodiversity we find on
earth
for our water to be clean and our soils
to be rich
we need healthy forests
trees and forests are true alleys in the
fight against climate and biodiversity
crisis
trees purify our air cool our cities
and take up co2 we need to be their
allies too
euros forests are not in a good shape
that's why we will work to protect and
restore them
we also need to improve how forests are
managed well managed for us
our vibrant european forest ecosystems
are key to our transition to climate
neutrality
by 2030 we want to add 3 billion
new trees and we want to make sure that
those are the right trees
in the right place for the right purpose
that's how we can restore nature
offer a home to more birds and insects
and help fight
the climate crisis every tree every
sapling
and every plant is one each
is important we need to start looking
differently at nature around us
we need to realize that wherever we see
green it benefits us
our children and our grandchildren in
the end
we are all part of nature what we do
to fight the climate and biodiversity
crisis we do for our own health
and future
[Music]